joe hamilton remortgaged her home to try
to repay a 36 thousand pound shortfall
that the post office's new i.t system
had detected
what she didn't know was that the
horizon accounting system was riddled
with flaws and defects and there was no
shortfall
joe ended up with a criminal conviction
for false accounting there's still a
culture of denial and well it wasn't me
it was him and you know well it was
somebody and hopefully we'll get to the
bottom of it and they're still refusing
to compensate the group that took
them to court the 555 that took them to
court in the first place
more than 700 post office staff were
prosecuted over two decades because of
this flawed system it is the most
widespread miscarriage of justice in
british legal history
belgium sethi and his wife anjana had
survived seven armed robberies at their
post office in essex but when the system
detected a shortfall
they lost everything
no amount of conversation
can return us the 20 years of hell we
have gone through
only my wife and i know it
how we have struggled in this 20 years
we have worked so many hours
for a petty amount of money
only 72 people have had their names
cleared so far
39 had their convictions quashed at the
court of appeal last april
it was horrific absolutely horrific
and we
i was in prison for um three months and
then i came out on tag for three months
and
it's something that
i wouldn't wish on my worst enemy it's
it was horrid
this inquiry will run for the rest of
the year and we'll hear evidence in
cardiff at the end of this month and in
leeds at the beginning of next month a
key part of its remit will be to find
out whether or not the post office knew
about the flaws in its it system
to this day nobody from the post office
or fujitsu who ran the system has been
held accountable
in the brady sky news in central london